A really fun question is that when astronauts
are in space they're not experiencing gravity,
so how does digestion work?
We sort of think of food moving down in our
bodies, it seems that maybe gravity would
have something to do with that.
The amazing thing is that it really doesn't
and this was one of the first things we discovered
when we sent animals first and then people
up into space.
Some people wondered if you could swallow,
if you could digest at all without the force
of gravity.
And it turns out that the act of peristalsis,
the way your throat and your intestines squeeze
themselves, will actually move food and water
through your digestive system without gravity
at all and you can even test that with people
lying in hospital beds.
When you think about somebody that's actually
lying down, there's no force of gravity that's
pulling food in one direction or the other.
The human body is actually pretty good at
moving food through without the force of gravity.
Now other part of this is what happens when
the food comes out the other end, because
this is a natural thing that all humans do
every day.
Well, you've now reached the wonderful science
of space toilets.
They actually act with suction.
Now if you've ever been to the dentist's office
and the dentist wants you to spit and he holds
up a little cup with a tube attached to it
and there's suction that takes the water down
the tube.
A space toilet acts very much that way; there's
suction, there's a current of air that actually
draws the waste down so it can be disposed
of.
And, honestly, sometimes it doesn't work perfectly.
This is one of the things that astronauts
have to deal with.
When you think about the word 'floater', that
has happened, where something escapes and
you need to go get it.
Some of the worst parts of human space flight
in the very early days, like in Gemini all
the way back in the 1960s, was people would
collect their urine in a little plastic bag
and sometimes they broke.
So there have been some people up there and
some very bad circumstances.
Today, the toilet on the space station works
very well and suction brings everything down
and the best thing I can compare it to is
the dentist's spit cup.
They actually have a little video camera so
you can see if anything is floating around
in the toilet before you get up.
Yeah.